Speaker 1: If you have something you want
to say to me and there's never an easy
transition out of out of a cancer diagnosis,
if you have something you want to say to me,
you can leave a voicemail at 219 to. David P The
eggman actually called in. We could use a little
levity. The man called in. And, you know, we did
this story yesterday about how Mike Pillow says
he's suing the FBI. He's suing everyone. And of
course, we all know how silly these lawsuits are.
Eggman says, you know, think about it. If your
pillow is lawyer or lawyers and, you know,
he's got $300 million, you'll sue whoever the
hell he wants you to sue. Take the money and
run. This is the ag man's perspective on that.
Speaker 3: Hey, Dave. Imagine you're Pillow's.
Speaker 2: Lawyer, one of his lawyers.
Speaker 3: At this meeting at Hardee's or Arby's,
wherever they go. And he says, maybe KFC to the
FBI, and we're going to sue the president. And
the lawyers are like, how do we take this man's
money? He has $30 million, billion dollars worth
of money, but still not do the ridiculous things
he wants. How do we placate this man? The lawyers
are telling him, sure, we'll sue the FBI for you,
Mike. Write the check. Write the check. So his
lawyers are getting loaded, probably laughing
their asses off at his insane request. It may
be. God imagine the waitress in that meeting is
probably smarter than all of them put together.
Speaker 2: So, yes.
Speaker 1: Shalom, of course. And very,
very soon we will be at Rosh Hashanah. Eggman
and Eggman. Eggman? Steve Eggman. No, the eggman.
Yeah. I think Eggman may be on to something with
Trump. It's sort of the opposite with Trump.
Lawyers don't want to represent him because
he'll often just never pay them with pillow.
Assuming pillow pays, lawyers will probably be
willing to do whatever pillow wants. Sue the
FBI? Sure. Or sue the Secret Service. Sue the CIA?
Yeah. Wait, why not? Let's sue everybody. If they
can actually rack up money from pillow ag men may
well be on to something. On today's bonus show,
we are going to talk about the first in the nation
law protecting children's online privacy. The law
is out of California. We will describe it and we
will discuss it for those of you who listen to the
first season of the serial podcast. Adnan Syed has
been released from prison and what that means if
you did not listen to the serial the first season,
you would know. But I'll be look, I will explain
all of it on today's bonus show. I think it will
be a really interesting conversation. And we are
also going to talk about the Illinois plan to
end cash bail and the and the criminalization
of poverty. It is not a perfect law. It's not.
But we don't want to let the perfect become the
enemy of the good, to quote the great Ted Kennedy.
And we will discuss that on today's bonus show.
You can sign up at join Pacman dot com. If you
missed yesterday's one day membership special
and you would like to take advantage, just
email in info at David Pakman dot com. Ask
for the coupon code and it shall be sent to
you so you can take advantage of it. We will
see everybody on the bonus show in a moment or
otherwise back here on the podcast tomorrow.